Sidney Evans knows what it's like to
live with debilitating pain relying on
medication to get through each day I was
like no solute bitters in November 2017
and I was immediately prescribed
hydroxychloroquine also known as plátano
currently have a little under a month
left hydroxychloroquine the drug that
Sydney takes has traditionally been used
to treat malaria and autoimmune diseases
like lupus when I flare up I experience
a lot of body pains and just difficulty
breathing and that stabbing pain in the
chest in the lung area after I was
diagnosed and put on this medicine I've
been able to live a good life it's also
the drug that Donald Trump has
aggressively pushed as a potential
coronavirus cure prompting people across
America to ask their doctor for a
prescription and pharmacies are running
out it is a little disheartening to know
that someone has medications sitting on
their shelves as they just in case they
need it um when there are thousands of
folks like me who definitely need it and
who rely on it every day and we can't
get it there's been very little research
on hydroxychloroquine effect on
coronavirus a French study that spot the
initial interest has been widely
discredited by the scientific community
but Donald Trump has given the drug a
whole new platform but what do you have
to lose they say take it I'm not looking
at it one way the other but we want to
get out of this if it does work it would
be a shame if we didn't do it early the
president has dismissed reports that he
has a financial stake in
hydroxychloroquine he puts his interest
down to common sense Donald Trump has
said hydroxychloroquine could be one of
the biggest game changers in medical
history without scientific evidence the
doctors on his own task force would
rather focus on social distancing but
the president wants the country back up
and running and he's looking for a quick
fix
Kovach 19 has hit New York harder than
anywhere else in the US some hospitals
are cautiously using hydroxychloroquine
all the doctors who are caring for these
patients around the world are struggling
with two things our desperate desire to
find a drug that works and a willingness
to try anything to try to save our
patients it doesn't mean that we don't
offer it as an option for patients but
we do not doubt that it is a cure-all we
don't even know whether it's beneficial
at all doctors are worried about
possible side effects particularly how
hydroxychloroquine affect a kovat 19
patients heart but as the death toll
rises people are grasping at any hope of
stopping the spread becky Cottrill Sky
News Washington